nous sommes au golf blue green 2,50 en
yvelines et nous allons tenter à 2 testé
le golf aujourd'hui pour m'aider dans
cette tâche je suis à côté de williams
williams le programme aujourd'hui
alors nous aujourd'hui en fait on va
d'abord commencer par faire du poitiers
pour faire un petit peu nos premiers
lancers ensuite on a fait ce qu'on
appelle du petit jeu donc c'est des
coups qui sont autour du drapeau et
ensuite en fait on va mettre des
ensembles à faire un parcours pour voir
un grand bain un petit peu ce que ça
donne c'est pas trop difficile non ça va
après faut juste insisté un petit peu
persévérer mais sinon c'est comme un
sport à l'extérieur c'est super agréable
donc c'est parti on va prendre les
matches aller
allez raconte dumas tel aviv a
donc là je tire de tout mais pas souvent
doucement pour commencer progressivement
on va augmenter ok ok la première
difficulté rencontrée
première difficulté taper la balle tout
simplement toucher la balle du coup je
prend de l'élan et après je fais avec
l'ensemble donc il va falloir en fait la
faire la même chose c'est-à-dire un jeu
prend de l'élan et 2 je vais utiliser
ensemble pour propulser la balle
[Musique]
lavallois c'est mieux pour tafer sera
fait je pense que c'est bon pour le
practice on va faire quoi maintenant on
va aller faire du coup du petit jeu
c'est bien on va récupérer quelques
balles puis en avant avec le soleil qui
arrive en plus
parce que tu as quelques conseils à me
donner oui alors du coup on va beaucoup
non plus quelques-uns on va se mettre
juste en face aux quais
en fait le petit c'est juste deux choses
à gérer vitesse et direction pour la
vitesse en fait ce qui est très
important c'est de faire un petit coup à
vide pour essayer de ressentir un petit
peu mouvement de balancier parce que la
vitesse du potter va donner en fait la
vitesse de la balle
donc c'est très important de préparer un
petit peu son dosage en regardant
régulièrement trou avant de jouer et
ensuite de bien prendre le temps dallier
baballe le potter et ensuite d'exécuter
ce qu'on a décidé comme dosage je vais
essayer de faire aussi bien on va voir
[Musique]
et tu vas donc du coup de maître à
courir regarder un petit peu comme un
ivrogne toujours rêvé de faire ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc c'est terminé ouais on va aller sur
le parcours mettre en place tout ça pour
voir les deux ensemble ce que ça va
donner exactement mais le but du jeu ce
week end et sur le parcours donc fait
partie on y va on se jette dans le grand
bain allez là du coup on est sur un
par-3 donc le passé l'objectif d'un
joueur professionnel pour un débutant c6
donc on va voir si après ces petits
conseils tu arrives du coup à faire
l'objectif
on va essayer à l'est
[Musique]
hier ça
[Applaudissements]
merci merci beaucoup en tout cas pour
cette session si on veut tester le golf
ici à saint quentin en yvelines comment
ça se passe
alors si on veut tester en fait on fait
des initiations payante jusqu'au 13
septembre
et à partir de cette date là en fait
jusqu'à fin octobre nous ont des
initiations gratuites donc ouvert à tout
le monde donc
venez nombreux et comme quoi c'est pour
tous les niveaux moi j'ai réussi à le
faire donc pourquoi pas vous merci
beaucoup williams avec plaisir et moi je
vais continuer un petit peu le golfe